it's a great honor for me to be here in
this stage my name is Eva marina on the
co-founder of Plaza 60 degrees creative
studio based in Bremen here in Germany
and in this talk you're going to see
what is the relationship and the
similarities between these two images
the correlations between art science and
engineering what I have encountered
doing real-time 3d projects I share tips
on managing large amount of data the
down sense of a very diverse
distribution landscape and we're having
so many options can overcome as our
wellness as creatives and how to base
our content a little bit about myself I
study Fine Arts design and engineering I
did two specializations one in digital
edition of the media and another one in
digital media media informatics we
haven't building tools in our studio
that helped us to create our projects
and help as well with the e-commerce
tools of some of our clients we have
been working with across different
industries and make some prototypes of
WebGL for the community
coming back to these two images how do
you think they are in any way similar
any ideas they both start with black
campuses deep use are machines that
perform 60 or 120 times what it took a
Renaissance a Mannerist or a baroque
painter between three to ten years to
succeed it is me I like to treat it this
way because it give me a scope of how
far we can get in the centuries it
reminds me that WebGL 3d frameworks and
game engines use in fact many of the
math develop since then in perspective
and geometry concepts are vanishing
point and other ideas used from an
engineer's are placed within their map
systems the introduction of the camera
obscura and optics made us rich here
artistic form were created with those
new developments thanks to the
technology developments at the time in
optics kalispera modeling appear
inspired by Greek illumination models
and we have been using them since then
in the production of painting images and
film since the Renaissance chaos
promoting the art of creating volume by
placing light on dark also called light
modeling light shading or simply shading
is where we have to look to understand
computer graphics gyroscope painting is
a negative version of regular painting
where you take a carbon or an oil paint
and stain on the product white canvas in
words of the Vinci Rubens the lastly
Velasquez Baglioni firm F
Rembrandt Caravaggio you will find all
these concepts and among other painters
we have a they had a beauty
understanding of the craft as a general
and how to create that imagery how to
mix the colors and how to the light
behave what rushes to use the venom of
the material they needed to be resemble
Remo Velasquez a Caravaggio they were a
little better because they managed to
their art in big campuses something that
it was not really possible due to the
technology that he was used at the time
something this doesn't mean that other
classical periods they were not
continuing with the development of their
art they continue until the destroyed
Revolution when the introduction of the
photography and film was introduced in
society and interest started there their
wares
there their art forms into different
mediums and into the 1970s some group of
artists recreate the concept of
hyperrealism
to resist the main photography the
mainstream photography in the arts and
GPUs thus the GPUs do that process
precisely with math and physics knowing
what brush or paint picture to take and
to use in your art will find your final
imagery output and your audience but how
do you do all this a little explanation
of how do pages work might be relevant
in this case there are two sides that
you need to take care the vertex buffer
or geometry buffer and the fragment
buffer or pixel buffer as the name
describing one handles the geometry both
data and the other one handles the
fragment but both are interconnected by
uniforms and attributes that move the
data types between both buffers and you
can transform them any single time in
butyl space and in virtual time the
amount of data that is loaded to these
buffers charges the performance budget
so you have to be careful in the way how
you are going to create your assets and
display it in their application find a
balance between them otherwise the
application might suffer the risk to get
blocked by the browser for user security
or user experience issues
how do we create those assets to have
that balance in your application first
I'm going to explain about the 3d
modeling capturing their multiple
madam's methods to create but one of the
most popular one is photogrammetry where
you surround your object with multiple
cameras and capture the images of that
object and then get all the data points
and put it in in your modeling program
there are two ways to do so the
cylindrical that uses a hexagonal
surround like in the picture and the
planner area where you take some drones
and you place some camels cameras on it
and you scan all the feel that you need
to this method is brave to create
complex environments racing games tracks
are done this way for video game
consoles for example and cylindrical
photogrammetry are done for human bodies
and more complex shapes another ways are
the red light laser scan to the object
the this method is pretty great for
reverse engineering on some objects and
is used very useful or the creation of
cars or other object there in industrial
production the most classical one method
to create the objects is by volumetric
drop or graphic from blueprint it's
precise it gives less noise data noise
within the correction but it takes a lot
of time a lot of time to optimize so
it's not cost-effective compared with
the other two methods once you have all
that you ready to remove the excesses by
running some tools in your 3d modeling
tool and you take out the vertex quality
and then manually your 3d team required
to arrange those vertices that there yet
miss can miss array and place the normal
vector perpendicular to the quad or
triangle in order to have accurate
representations of lights and
reflections in the surface of your
object
the creation of textures is also
important and these use methods like
with photo cameras as well when you take
a photograph the photograph of the
texture that you want to replicate and
adjust it in a image processing tool
like Photoshop or something like that
and adjust the values of the
illumination in all the pixels and
accommodated for being able to be
terrible once you have that texture you
can reduce some information from their
channels and then you can create other
textures like the normal Maps or the
bone maps and so on the way how you
arrange the state your these textures in
your shader program are going to
transform the different visual output so
you have to be careful how you arrange
in and you have to play with those
textures and adjust them and you will
see how the final material is going to
be represented in your display and for
that it is necessary for you to have
some understanding of shading
programming and there are sterilization
methods of your 3d rendering engine
whatever it is it's important but
realistic 3d are large applications so
you have to treat them like big
applications in JavaScript there require
many data so the loading process can be
long there are many presentations
already in this video comfort in this
video conference is where you can take
information into of how to create the
large applications but the generally
speaking the advice will be the same you
have to reduce the server cause when
loading scripts and assets as much as
possible loath first scripts and styles
load them textures I like to initialize
the fragment shaders after right after I
finished loading the textures and create
the materials and right after that I
will load the data to the geometry data
and initialize the birthday shaders and
wrap those geometries with the fragment
shaders previously created
I like to follow this path because the
creation of the overall of both buffers
is very heavy for the machine so you can
crash the application and your
experience can get broken at that point
once all this process is over the rest
of the journey is going to be very
smooth creating lighting is important
because adds volume to the objects to
the scene and you need to have a
lighting model that is going to be
uniform in all the materials here we are
as smart as it is he's not a smart just
drag and drop a file format and having a
triple a graphics card of the Box in
deity gives you some advances but you
have to play with the values of your
materials until you find the right
balance of it we will see that some
materials when the light is getting too
close the material is going to get over
illuminated and I'm going to burn and
another materials are going to get very
OPAC and they're gonna be flat looking
very flat so play with those values and
you're going to be find your balance in
there one of the good things about PBR
is that it contains previous models like
lambda illumination or Phong
illumination
so those illuminations give some visual
artifacts for you to play when you don't
really require to have all them at the
textures in the intent that TV requires
the compute illumination on textures as
known as big illumination is also a good
performance tip usually we use that when
the in a level design where the camera
is not gonna get so close to the
environment or the area that is going to
be display and it's a way a great way to
see the resources that you can use in
another areas of your application like
in the protocol figure 8 or the object
that it requires to look realistic
in product figures the electric model is
fixed and it's a little bit more easier
than their walkthroughs for example or
in game design in level design because
the the light is fixed and you can
surround it with your camera all the
time
so the there's no need to move the
cameras for the lights for all the time
when the camera moves like in the
walkthroughs some engines cool both the
geometries and the lights others they
just call the geometries so depending on
that you choose what illumination to
take my recommendation is that you have
to go to Target 3 a minimum of 3 lights
and the maximum of 6 lights including
the sunlight if you are building daily
scene balance this with the material
properties and that will be given to you
more performance space for the more
geometric testers
what's processing is important for very
visual results
it's a second layer of the process in
the pipeline but it's expensive for the
machine but it gives another advance
because you can have an extra layer of
color correction or illumination and
adjust this of of pixels you can
transform at this point with the
fragment shaders your image since these
are is rasterize already by the by the
renderer is in a one single image and
you can apply any type of models in
there like neighboring pixel is pixels
and you can transform make it more
bright move them in two in two
dimensions and create all the
psychological effects that developers
like to do play with those values until
you find your final imagery and you are
happy with the visual look that you have
that you want to desire
now the was diversification of hardware
has brought us great opportunities but
at the same time stillness
because find that the next path to take
can be hard
waves obvious information due to these
many mediums were expecting to happen
and we are a little bit confused in how
to move around in the development
process there is an order of
developments that needs to be addressed
I recommend first two steps the first
step to target mobile and desktop and
based on that move to other mediums I'm
going to speak about precisely with
butyl reality and augmented reality in
mobile with mobile devices because it's
what it might come faster and reach is
more audience and the reason why it's
this order that I recommend is because
if the application doesn't perform okay
with your basic configuration options is
not going to perform or look the same
neither in your virtual reality or
augmented reality application and all my
previous comments that I have done with
modeling and creating textures and how
to arrange your application are useful
for all these mediums immutability is
not that easy as just to divide the
screen for each eye that comes with
attacks and you had to play with
depending on your application
requirements how high that that task
could be and make some compromises
mirrors for example is another complex
part of the virtual reality and
augmented reality
[Music]
because you have to have many cameras in
in rendering and hardware is not going
to support that all the 3d rendering
frameworks that exist on game engines in
JavaScript they come with controls for
easy integration so you can program it
otherwise can create those controls
easily in the case of a are reflections
can be hard as well because we can have
access to all the dimensions of the
environment once the user is on a
specific geographical position you don't
have access to that so most of these
applications they have the pretty
compute is illuminate reflections
textures so the visuals are not going to
look as great as if the application
we're going to be developed in indoors
environment the lighting is also very
difficult for the that reason for
similar reasons and we cannot have
access to the illumination that is
happening and outside environments if
it's cloudy if it's not cloudy if the
Sun is over the specific time so that
affects the final output and that is
something that it takes some time to to
reach to have high fidelity like in
indoors development where you have
control of the illumination and control
of the how the environment looks so the
application can looks very okay with it
this approach for example work to other
ties meant billboards art works in art
galleries or dealership presentations in
dealership stores or retail stores and
so on be careful with the amount of data
that you're going to use in your
augmented reality application because
you have to allocate some memory for the
camera rendering which is going to be in
high definition
so that's some cost in there as well
that is not that you cannot use for the
3d data plaza gia the geographical
position tracking system
he will take some memory and that system
we are going to get the plain ground
where we're going to address or
development of the scene and as
conclusions here Escudo is deeply
embedded in computer graphics the
relevance of arts influencing technology
is not just in selecting colors
typography for the interfaces adjusts
for computing tones when possible
because that open space for more data to
be computed and more space for data to
be computed means that you have more
room for improve your graphics the waste
way to learn is getting information from
other duals whether by books
documentaries presentation scientific
papers etc and apply those concepts with
trial and error experimentation target
mobile first depth of after and later
other mediums what's next for photo
realism in web technologies well we are
following close what video game consoles
can do we expect to have better ray
tracing methods and more accurate
illumination models in the future more
beautiful reality augmented reality and
its reality of the adoption is happening
and is expected to increase use WebGL or
hardware as a rated api's for 2d and 3d
rendering as much as possible because
with that power of your disposal to be
used you can render more data or analyze
more data don't be afraid of it dig into
it and use that power to extend your
design and artistic capabilities I hope
that I brought some useful information
to you today and I clear some questions
you may have
this is under the present accessing
topic and it's hard to fill it in a 2025
minutes talk if you would like to keep
talking about this you can drop me a
line at my email address or you can
write me on Twitter
we can talk about this or something that
I call that net our hyperrealism the
rules of it
the manifesto it happens I have been
written and the future items thank you
so much for your attention and for being
here after the great party last night
[Applause]